still not sure what I am I'm just living
my life day to day you should be out
there helping people you think I asked
me this I was putting some tank like
exotic fish came up with abilities I
just want to be left the hell alone
that would be a waste
Harlen the cultural symbol of hope and
prosperity
too much happens in the shadows people
fear what they can't see
places our reputation our medicine our
blood it every businessman squeezed hard
everybody wants to be the king
sometimes if you want justice you have
to get it yourself
give us the money I don't like your tone
you have my word ma'am I've got you
a cleaner praises please on the back
door go to war now take you to war you
might be bulletproof
the Harlem eight
this is supposed to represent our hopes
and dreams you have to fight for what's
right every single day
why don't you just tell us your name the
whole neighborhood is yapping about how
two goons got the beatdown last night I
heard it was four guys
hey youtubers is charlie new luke age
Powerman
just watch everyone get rekt so let's
break it down so i like the introduction
here luke age just shows up and saves
rosario dawson so you know that there
are characters crossing over from the
other Netflix series obviously they're
all gonna cross over before defenders
I'm expecting to see a whole lot of Iron
Fist during the series but the trailers
just like an expanded version of a lot
of the stuff they showed off at
comic-con so one of the happiest moments
in this was when he climbed out of the
tank and I'm like oh my god they're
doing the origin story so if he didn't
know Luke Cage was part of an experiment
trying to replicate the Captain America
Super Soldier Serum it went wrong like
there was a big accident he got
electrified in the tank and that's what
gave him his variation on his Captain
America powers because impenetrable skin
aside his strength is very comparable to
Captain America's he might even be a
little bit stronger because he was so
much stronger before he went in the
program so for all intents and purposes
he is the Captain America of Harlem and
that's kind of the way the people they
are talking about him in the trailer
like misty Knight is like you might be
bulletproof but Harlem ain't and if it
wasn't clear from the trailer this is
picking up after the end of Jessica
Jones so like at the end of Jessica
Jones he takes off and goes back to
Harlem to hide out just because all the
trouble that happens during that series
he kind of explains his backstory to
Jessica Jones when they're talking to
each other just like oh yeah you know
try the superhero thing didn't work out
I try to take care of me and mine but
he's also trying to keep it on the DL
but he gets really upset when he thinks
that trouble is coming his way so he
blows up his own bar during that series
to try and keep it under the radar so
that people don't come looking for him
but obviously he trouble finds him
because he goes home to Harlem and
everyone's like dude you are a hero
be a hero help save your town so a lot
of you are probably asking before this
is he you know where the classic costume
at all we gonna sit he nods to that the
tank is probably the closest we'll get
to that like he climbs out of the tank
with the headband and the wristbands on
that's as close as we're getting to the
70s costume the way the children are
talked about this series is that it's
kind of like the wu-tang off' occation
of the Marvel Universe so it's way more
hip-hop than its funk that's why they
use that ODB wu-tang song in the last
trailer which I thought was like the
perfect way to introduce the character
this
trailers just like a much bigger version
of that people asking is misty night
gonna get her stark tech bionic arm I'm
not expecting that to happen during this
series they played a little more real
than that but because in the comics
she's Danny rands girlfriend I'm
expecting her to cross over to iron fist
when we get to that series - so do not
be surprised if Danny ran shows up at
the very end of this series you know
most of this is gonna be Luke Cage
trying to clean up Harlem him going up
against cottonmouth who's going to be
like the kingpin of the series King is a
very important thing to you look at the
imagery here with the Biggie Smalls like
crown image it's a very important image
in the context of hip-hop especially
East Coast hip-hop from the 90s you know
East Coast versus West Coast if you guys
remember the Tupac vs. biggie small
stuff back in the 90s but there's a very
game of Thrones
everyone wants the Iron Throne everyone
wants to be King vibe to it
so cottonmouth is kind of like the
kingpin of the series and that he also
wants to help Harlem so he's more like
the stringer Bell of the series for
those of you that have watched the wire
stringer Bell you know funny enough you
know to talk about marvel crossover and
the wire stringer Bell was played by
idris elba who was kind of like this
aspirational drug dealer figure who
consolidated a lot of power wanted to go
legit but we also know that a Drusilla
is heimdal in the Marvel Universe so
it's just like a nice crossover between
those two so I'm thinking of him is like
a more raw version of stringer Bell
someone who likes to think of themselves
as educated cultured someone who can
bring order but then goes the kingpin
route where you become the villain of
the story but I think the really big
difference between this series in
daredevil in that relationship between
kingpin and daredevil with cottonmouth
and Luke Cage is that the Luke Cage
series itself will be so much more
vicious like if you remember how angry
the hip hop Ward's got during the 90s
like how deadly they got imagine a
version of that playing out in the
Marvel Universe with these characters
but I just love the way they frame this
visually like where he's standing with
the crown above his head and then at the
end of the trailer they even used the
word defender so like they really want
you to start thinking about the big
defenders team-up because we are getting
pretty close they're actually shooting
the defenders in New York right now
let's see I think I already talked about
him just getting right like I just love
this moment where the gangbangers in the
Chinese restaurant and he just does not
know what is a
punches Luke Cage and bam and this
Walter Mosley book that he's reading is
very appropriate to it's almost like
Luke Cage reads comic books and that
inspires him to become a hero so the
book that he's reading a little easy
green I've obviously appropriate to the
villains story trying to get a little
easy green but the story itself is like
a hard-boiled detective story about a
protagonist that answers the call again
like he picks up the case of this
missing person and he tries to clean the
city up so it's like Luke Cage is
reading this story about this black
detective who cleans up his town one
step at a time but I really like the way
the metaphor plays visually like Luke
Cage reading comic books and is inspired
by the heroes in those stories to be a
hero himself and that's kind of the
story of the series Luke Cage realizing
great power great responsibility decides
to become the defender of Harlem and you
know I said you're great power great
responsibility spider-man kind of like a
combination of a street-level hero in an
a-list Avenger all these series even
though there isn't a lot of crossover
like physical crossover between the
movies and the TV shows this is
happening real time so right now in the
Marvel Universe just like a hop over the
East River in Queens Peter Parker is
getting ready to start his sophomore
year in high school so this is
effectively picking up after the events
in civil war for those of you wondering
where the time line is so let me know
like what are you most excited for in
this Luke Cage story I know everybody
wants to see the origin story and
everybody wants to see some Iron Fist
Heroes for Hire Easter eggs so what I'm
expecting is is that Danny ran will pop
up somewhere near the very end of this
series but for the most part it's just
going to be Luke Cage and he'll be
referring to stuff that happened during
Jessica Jones
so giveaway time congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner Arturo jr. Ortega
you win a $20 Amazon gift card sweet
Christmas
yay for giveaways so be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details there
is a new round that starts now - there's
a whole bunch of marvel and DC stuff
happening this week so all you have to
do to enter the giveaway is just be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video there was some more thor ragnarok
they dropped we learned more about some
of the villains they are doing Fenris
wolf and fire Lords serger so i'll do a
video for that later this week but
there's a whole bunch of movie stuff and
TV stuff happening between Marvel and DC
so I'll try to get all those videos out
in the next couple days so while you
guys wait for that video to post I was
just talking about spider-man you can
click here to learn about the villains
of spider-man homecoming super deep cuts
from the comics and you can click here
to learn more about what's going on with
the second Man of Steel movie they are
making another superman movie thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight